crazy question for you guys yes crazy
question fast forward
10 20 years you're grown up you get
married you have kids let's say you both
have two daughters oh god okay that's a
curse yeah well pat has two boys two
daughters abortion
let me tell you karma's a [ __ ] and i
can see you both having some daughters
i'm just letting putting that out there
yeah hopefully they're healthy and
beautiful and amazing
i want to hear the advice that you would
tell your daughters
break your question
so honestly speaking
now fresh if you need to take a second
bro and take a sip of water go ahead
but i wanted the advice that you would
tell your daughters
man okay so don't be a hoe you want the
truth uh i want it all right get as
graphic and as insightful as you
possibly can i wish you're a boy but let
me not start there um no because
damn it man no you go first yeah okay
maybe we're gonna help you i'll just
tell them i'm gonna be mean the truth
like i'm i would tell her like a lot of
the things i tell the girls on a pod you
know like understand that your past
defines you as a woman unfortunately
that's just the way it is like you know
men do care about the carfax you know
you want a male in the future he's gonna
want a woman that doesn't have a pass so
that she doesn't [ __ ] up his future and
that's just the way men are especially a
guy that's worth a damn he's gonna have
a lot of stake in your past so that's
number one uh you know i would tell her
go to school and obviously get your
career and everything else like that but
understand that
you know you also need to pay take that
same vigor and apply it to finding the
right guy and i would be involved in in
her finding a guy as well i think that's
a big mistake that a lot of women make
is that they don't involve you know i
always say to really get the best um how
do i to find the best guy you need a
male on your team right that has your
best self interest no not a guy friend
that's trying to smash you that's on the
side like your dad your brother someone
that is related to you that doesn't have
a sexual interest in you that actually
likes you for you and loves you for you
the closest to un you know um to ideal
love and they will tell you this guy is
a worse [ __ ] this guy isn't worth it
whatever and a lot of girls don't
involve their brother or their or their
uh father because you know it's awkward
or i don't want him involved whatever
and then they're picking the [ __ ] boys i
don't want to take them seriously
because women run off emotion this guy
makes me feel a certain way so i'm going
to deal with him even though he's a
terrible example so uh or a terrible uh
potential mate so i would be involved in
that i would also let her know the
uncomfortable reality is that yo your
past does matter your career doesn't
matter that much as well as well like
you know you can go to school and
everything to be sufficient but
understand that that's not going to make
you more marketable or attractive to a
man you know and i'll just give her the
uncomfortable realities about men and
women are very different i think we live
in a world now where we tell young girls
whatever taste of career you're the same
as a man you can do anything a man can
do well obviously we know that's not
true because when a transgender man
enters ncaa as a swimmer now he's a
champion he was ranked 400 some and now
he's beating the [ __ ] out all these
girls it's like men and women are not
the same we're different at certain
things men excel certain things women
excel certain things and for you to use
a male metric of success is going to
make you miserable long term how about
you well yeah so definitely um i'll tell
you the truth you know because i don't
lie to her i'll give her two options if
you want a man here's what you do if you
want to be a whole it's what you do as a
result i can't force her to be what
she's going to be she's going to choose
you know on her own but i'll say this
i'll tell them look at in the day men
want sex
but what do you want do you want a
family or do you want to be you know
flying out here doing your thing as a
result choose the power if you want to
take and and i'll just say this as well
you're gonna get you're gonna get [ __ ]
over however how you react to it is
gonna determine you know what you do for
example some girls will get heartbroken
and they go on a spiral where they go
like [ __ ] every every guy they see
because you're just mad or whatever
yo at this point what do you really want
daughter do you want to be uh successful
do you want to be with a man you want to
have imagined kids follow that path so
but most women when they're
you know
look the girls that are 21 to 24 they
operate completely differently from the
girls who are 27 to 32. yeah totally
like it's not even close
so
they're having fun yolo and then as a
girl it's that other thing it's like
okay you know i need to slow down and
find a guy yeah see here's problem right
you can tell your daughter what to do
but bro when it comes to like what she
sees in front of her bro
like nigga's got game nigga's got money
[ __ ] lifestyle
that program you give to her this first
period of time once you get certain age
is like oh this is fun my friends are
doing it i'm gonna have fun and live my
lifestyle yolo now pat you've got four
kids i assume the conversations you have
with the boys are gonna be different
than you're gonna have with the girls i
mean santa's five
brooklyn's a baby but
walk us through how you're processing
this as a father it's a risk i mean you
just have to know you're facing a risk
you know when you were talking about
you're calling 13 years old that that's
picking up if a 13 year old guy calls me
out to want to talk to the girl
i'm calling sammy the bullet saying hey
you know i need a favor but no uh all
jokes aside i think the dynamics varies
based on who's the oldest and the
youngest let me explain if you got a boy
first
and then you have a girl
and the age difference you have two
examples two layers of security
if you got two boys and then you have
two girls you now have three layers of
security for the girls which is the
oldest and the young so like for example
tico is not that protective tico's
personality is more chill
with how he is but dylan dylan is the
dylan's going to be like you do
something to senna you're going to
you're going to have to deal with dylan
and dylan's got to have a different
personality but at the same time he gave
very good advice he said
someone's going gonna screw you over
then what are you gonna do because it's
gonna happen right it's gonna happen
what are you gonna do when somebody
screws you over your boyfriend does this
to you you're gonna go on revenge and
go hook up with every single one of her
friends one of his friends and trying to
get back at him is that what you're
going to do because that's when you
really learn it is going to take place
to you i think the other part you got to
think about as well as your values and
principles and how you treat the mom the
way you treat the mom she's watching and
the way you treat her she's going to
think that's how i want to be treated
one day because odds are my dad my
daughters are probably one of them is
going to date a guy like me and if they
date a guy like me
and i know who i am
i know that dynamics of how he's going
to want to be leading that family and
she's going to watch you see here's how
you take care of mom here's how i want
him to take care of me as well those
dynamics is gonna be you can say
whatever you want manual book
28 keys to be in this and that she's
listening to nothing facts she's just
watching to what you're doing period
she's going to duplicate and go after
the way you live your life uh that
example is going to do more more for you
than having her you know
22 books girls on the show that have a
better grasp on like dating and what
they really want for managing kids their
father was a good example to them and
that's what they saw now what did they
hear your daddy issues what they saw so
that does help in terms of getting them
not directly guys are so important man
yeah it's it's amazing how like uh dads
are not respected in the west and
drawing oh you don't know man i don't
need kids like i always say a strong dad
will keep a girl up for sure pull and
son's out of jail yep you know your dad
is the first line of defense to keep you
from becoming a degenerate to society
but the main job of a man is to keep his
daughter off the pole yeah yeah
mission number one and and patrick uh no
lie i remember this story way back when
uh his his daughter or my daughter
sister sister paulette he said uh hey my
sister paulette's gonna visit
potentially this that the other i'm like
oh you got a sister
right and swings patrick was like listen
man i'm gonna tell you this you're my
brother and i love you you do anything
or look in the wrong direction of my
sister you're gonna have to deal with me
so i can imagine you know tico or dylan
would be the same thing so those layer
of defense i definitely know he's not
lying without saying that one day she'll
tell some of the stories publicly and
you're going to crack up with some of
the stories of what happened with her
boyfriends one time she was dating this
one guy
and she told she the guy told her you
know what she wanted to hear which is i
love you okay
and then he screwed up royally
well he went to world's gym which one of
my friends was working out there and my
friend knows that guy who the guys and i
said listen if you guys see him in the
street i don't care where you are beat
the living [ __ ] out of this guy and i
rarely say that award on
podcast but he went there it was a bad
setting for him the guy was walked out
he had a bad situation never went back
to the gym never went back to that gym
again and then we had a christian my i
come back for christmas this is when my
i was bad at that time i was not in a
good manner you knew me at that 18 18
we go to church my dad's i want you to
go to syrian church i'm not going to
syrian church he said i want you to
dress in your military uniform and come
to church i'm wearing my greens okay
and i go to church paulette's standing
right here he shows up
damn
he shows up so my dad at this point is
like
he says you can't do anything it's
everybody i said that that's not that's
not how i'm wired he says you can't do
anything i said somehow what he said in
church i'm at church
he says you can't do anything promise me
that's my present that's why you're here
i said that i can't i'm not wired like
that you can't he shows up so the
brother first shows up his name is his
similar name is me and then he shows him
i'm just holding him and i'm just
pulling him inside i'm pulling this and
i whisper something in his ears and then
he walked out here's the craziest thing
nine years later i recruit him to be an
agent recruiter not even kidding with
you wow 11 years ago and i'm training
and i'm 32 years old he's sitting in
front of me
i'm like
what the what are you doing here
he says hey bro i said dude it was a
long time ago how you doing how you
feeling he says uh just man i just
remember i said no we're cool man i gave
him a hug but it was a very unique
situation
but you know there's there's a dynamic
of sister where you have to protect and
you got to teach the kids that they have
to know that but it's a sensitive topic
when you have girls and no matter what
you do you ain't god you're not around
them they're going to make a lot of
noise i will say this because i have a
younger sister and she was the girl when
i was a senior and she was a freshman
all the boys yo adam's sister like yeah
oh man if you tell a girl
you can do whatever you want just don't
do this one thing she's gonna do that
that is exactly what the girl will do
yeah i had i had um
my friend jenny she was on the show
her older brothers would tell her these
are the guys that you cannot date she
goes i dated every single one of them of
course there's something in a female i
don't even know it's human nature you
tell someone don't put your hand on the
stove it'll burn it don't it's not
they're gonna put their hands it's both
men they're gonna put their hand on how
we are but go back in time adam and eve
what was the one thing you can't do
don't eat the apples i knew there was a
pastor in this guy listen the more i
listen to fresh this guy's like a closet
pastor about to be you know he's gonna
run one of the biggest churches five
thousand members you see him on stage if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]